Find the area of a square
with side 6x minus 5y.
So if you have a square, all the
sides are going to be the
same length, and they're
telling us the
length is 6x minus 5y.
The height will also
be 6x minus 5y.
And if you wanted to find the
area of the square, you would
just multiply the width times
the height, or you would
multiply 6x minus 5y
times 6x minus 5y.
Or another way to think about
it is you're taking 6x minus
5y to the second power,
or you're
taking 6x minus 5y squared.
That's why raising something to
the second power is called
squaring it because you're
essentially finding the area
of a square.
You're going from one dimension
to two dimensions.
That's where the term
squared comes from.
Now, when you square something,
you can just do the
distributive property
twice like we've
done in several videos.
But a shortcut when you square
something, and it all just
comes from working it out by
doing the distributive
property twice, is you can
square the first term, so
it'll be 6x squared, and then
you can take the product of
both terms and multiply it by
2, so times 2 times 6x times
negative 5y.
And then you can square
the last term.
Let me do it in a new color.
So plus negative 5y squared.
So that's the last
term right there.
This is the product
of both of them.
You multiply it by 2 and that
will be this quantity squared.
And you can get there by just
doing the distributive
property twice, or FOIL, however
you want to do it, but
this is a quicker way so that
when you see a squared, you
can immediately get to this.
And just working it out,
you get 6x squared is
36x squared, right?
6 squared times x squared.
And then you have a negative--
let's see, 2 times 6 times 5.
That is negative 10 times
6, so it's negative 60.
And then we have an x and a
y, xy, and then all of the
constants, when you multiply
them, you get negative 60.
And then finally, you have a
plus negative 5y squared.
So what is negative 5 squared?
Negative 5 squared
is positive 25.
And then y squared is
just y squared.
And we're done!
We found the area of the square
with side 6x minus 5y.
It's represented by this
expression right here.